arco due perché mi si deve avviare
sempre a icona sto gioco perché bene a
tutti i ragazzi e per rivivere la
partita la musica in sottofondo mi sono
gasatissimo guido e andrea tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuto che sono video sono
pari j
oggi siamo dati su piazza in glory
scusami perché non funziona più la trota
morivano se cliccato da sempre meno
violenti questi giochi proviamo ragazzi
la prima di oggi che the flow che non so
cosa voglia dire morte ma una donna
tutti i caldissimi
siccome ragazzi l'ultima volta che ho
giocato a casa in gloria mi sono non
sono proprio esperti in questo gioco è
però la cosa strana è che non sono morto
ma pd si così non ti schiacciano tipo i
cosi takeshi's cast sono finti bei
ragazzi che sono ricordate che ci scarse
chi se lo ricorda raga la merita la mia
stima perché c'è era la vita ho appena
giocato a pallone con una lama però lo
faccio sempre
muoio per essere caduto da un centimetro
va bene chi vuole un pezzo del mio piedi
in regalo laga anche della gamba adesso
siccome è passato un po di tempo
all'ultimo episodio sono tipo una
settimana non sono più allenato bene
quindi faccio poca gare scusatemi prova
a dare il mio massimo perfetto meglio
del solito raga bene non fatemi domande
bene così vai avanti alla madonna è
veramente perché ci scassati solo
scherzando prima sono io non è vero
scherzavamo poi andar dritto senza
sbilanciarti grazie 06 molto gentile
perfetto e fin qua sono cagato cosa è
successo
sono anche mara come avevo fatto
l'azione della vita e non erano a chi è
caduto michele incredibile e poi muoio
così con un deficiente ma con 100 100
100 mar di garris cento
e vabbè non era poco 130 ma quasi mi
chiedo sei andato a 100 chilometri orari
con la bici vi dico solo questo
64 tensione e si va a comandare ragazzi
in mezzo alle colline andiamo a fare tra
tutti quelli che c'era non c'era anche
la montagna dell'agonia che non l'avevo
ancora fatta l'altro questo nome non
posso non averla parte impossibile è uno
dei livelli più votati in assoluto e ci
sarà un motivo che io probabilmente non
capisco che non ho mai visto una vicenda
da 100 chilometri orari ragazzi c'è
prima ha battuto i record in record
factor
fin qua ma ci passò sotto sono inutili
se trappole ok ma scusate che montagna
dell'agonia sc passo in mezzo c'è easy
guardali fenomeno mica però ha prima
parte l'ho superata già tutta genio
inizia a farsi difficile ragazzi ma
niente che non possa risolvere forse una
freccia in testa potrebbe però essere un
problema
se invece di essere frettoloso ti becchi
tutte le frecce che ti meriti o vedi un
paio di frecce diventi un porcospino
però a veloce la fai che prova chi è
stato
vi ammazzo le famiglie ha tanto fatto da
qua perfetto ma in breve lancerà cioè
non c'entro sono vivono il succo ahia
ahia
e vabbè troppo morto scherzavo dai zio
ciò a cui fare impegnati maledizione ok
ok di qua non posso annunciare mio
figlio e mezzane pane scherzavo va bene
non ti incazzare però in teoria non è
ammessa cv in teoria è ok poter usare un
mezzo alle bombe sei serio come viene
esattamente così che volevo che andasse
però che il prefetto grandissimo che
slalom braga un fenomeno o le persone
questi assi da stiro questa roba arcodia
sono caduti
se sono riusciti a alla terra vi spieghi
ok no alla luce che poi era lì porca eva
lo sapevo lo sapevo
geniale fa vj bravo complimenti ma
giocare così bravo che sono un pericolo
anche in bici l'altro le macchine cosa
non ti riesce nel tenere il manubrio
dritto qualche ma senza che ha portati
senza fare cose strane vai dritto
ho fatto anche uno spin di 360
fantastico e sono morto malissimo però
lo spinge l'ho fatto ragazzi qui rendete
conto che non ce la posso fare non c'è
modo di passare in mezzo
stavo scherzando anche stavolta il bene
che mi smentisco subito dopo fantastico
gli olo a sovrani alla fine e finale
raga non ci credo
[Musica]
sei fantastico grazie zio grave lo
dicevo lo dici tu e ve lo dice mia mamma
però siete tutti e due molto gentili
grazie alla musica del menu di questo
gioco e orgasmica per avere ragione tb
maicon giorno il team mi voglio provare
a vedere se riesco in partenza di merda
ok perfetto
cosa ho fatto
crema che trovata però secondo me non si
è fatto malissimo quindi scusami tu vuoi
dirmi che io prendo quale check point e
poi devo andare giugno ma cazzo ma io
volevo salire da in quel modo lì era più
figo stai calmo è perfetto grazie tizio
che l'anci le le lame dal cielo però in
questo momento non mi servivano molto
però grazie per il pensiero
madonna ha amato la madonna senza gambe
senza niente 130 devono tagliare la
pianta la tua gamba monca non è che ti
aiuta tanto vero zio non è che ti è non
facciamo domande ragazzi grazie
avevo proprio bisogno marca è ma poi non
faccio la sua 0 non puoi un team guidati
ti prego iddio regista bici fai vedere
chi sei capace perché mio padre un
emerito idiota o un'ora e mezza cioè
avete vi rendete conto dello schifo
grazie cielo bisogno di questa freccia
nel bene vedo che ci vado anche convinto
pensando di vincere l'urgente d'affetto
perfetto bravo zio ben e rhys e così il
conto ci crede
sono arrivato regalo di lancio ma
[ __ ]
quanto sei disagiato zio ok ma in su
[ __ ] o va bene va bene un importante
shell check point cioè poi tesi va a
comandare ragazzi se ne fotte quanto
sarebbero belli check point e nella vita
reale
senza gamba ma non sta scritto da
nessuna parte che le gambe sermoni ai
ragazzi di fare l'ultimo perché questa
volta che pitt e curriculum e ancora non
ho capito perché e curriculum chi cazzo
tradotto questo gioco topo gigio lasci
andare a non drammatizzare maltrattati
di coccole
[Musica]
un mega ramp dire che l'ultima da fare
per oggi raga può essere mega ramp che
di casa un sacco partire partire mega
ramp dove sta migrando e non la vedo
non è così mega allora ok non avevo
vista scusate e poetico quanto sia
tranquillo lui ad andare in bici su una
rampa così grossa la madonna si
raggiunge il traguardo laica ce la fa ce
la fa non ce la fa perché sono troppo le
navate possibile che la bce ha posto
timi benissimo premio ragazzi con air la
che sicuramente più va più veloce di
quanto andavo io prima l'avevano sicuro
spinta massima baisi ormai zio bacio
bacio che siamo già 100 senza turbo vai
col turbo 180 era vita se vai storto
anche tu mamma mia lo schifo porca vacca
provato la giusta la traiettoria niente
ma ce la posso fare
ci vuole solo un po di impegno alla
madonna baisi ora il g8 di tutti noi zio
sei tutti noi 140 magica di chi sa
quanto sei store però più semplice prima
dai ragazzi prima di erle che sbanda se
non sbandasse sto maledetto sarebbe
anche più il di un dritto dritto dritto
bravissimo da in se no non ci credo mica
quante di noi non è possibile
raga the young family proviamoci con
degli anche family è l'ultima con la
bici non riesco con il quad non riesco
che la macchina è la macchina dovrei
riuscirci fino a proprio
maria è la madonna musica d'atmosfera
vuoi dirmi questa volta sono andato
troppo forte
wow allora che approvo senza turbo senza
turbo può darsi che io ci riesca
arrivano almeno 150 il che è buono
magari senza turbare stesso ecco lo
sapevo
ragazzi non ci andava il turbo era solo
questa la questione ma ci credo ma che
culo mica mi sono fermato prima che che
culo vela traguardo bella fratello
ricordate i ragazzi il turbo non è
sempre la risposta il masturbo e la
risposta servi dai piaciuta reazione
certamente vi piace al capo di facebook
anche i vari social minchia sono
riuscito a ridire la pagina di facebook
dopo una vita che non lo dicevo più
pollice in su per questo anche per il
socio è quella descrizione il seme se la
crisi fiscale temi civili hanno
proseguito
beh ragazzi
[Musica]